happy Friday everyone I am Tom shallou
in for Greg Gutfeld who said he had to
go save some orphans at least that's
what he texted me anyway let's welcome
tonight's guests
she serves her financial reports with
baked beans and collard greens co-host
of the bottom line on Fox Business
taking McDowell
he took me out to dinner and he asked
for a copay host of ask Dr Drew Dr Drew
Pinsky
when she goes on a ranch she packs a
suitcase Fox News contributor Kat Tim
[Applause]
and to him Big Ben is just Ben the nwa's
World Heavyweight Championship
okay before we get to some new stories
let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yes it's leftovers where I read the
jokes we didn't use this week and just
like Greg does it this is my first time
reading these okay here we go
this week President Biden delivered
numerous gaffes during his G7 speech but
when officials mentioned the name G7
Biden wouldn't stop screaming bingo
a new study finds that New York City
ranked dead last as worst places to
start a career and a lot of people who
work in New York would agree
wow oh wow
oh
Sylvester Stallone's daughters confessed
that their father would write breakup
texts that they would send their
boyfriends the boyfriends were
suspicious because the first four texts
were pretty good but then the quality
dropped off in the sequels
I gave him four
four
during an episode of The View Whoopi
Goldberg gave Sonny Hosten a lap dance
since she said she'd never seen one
Witnesses say it's the first time people
threw cash to stop a lap
the city of Baltimore is suing Kia and
Hyundai for making their cars too easy
for criminals local criminals to steal
though in the criminal's defense they
were trying to leave Baltimore
[Laughter]
yeah
despite recent controversy many Florida
residents say it's still home to the
happiest place on earth
the Spearmint Rhino gentlemen's club in
West Palm Beach
some residents
researchers at the University of South
Carolina have halted a series of
experiments on cocaine addicted rats but
without the cocaine the rats have lost
the motivation to work on Wall Street
yeah
yeah and go after them this week Jeff
bezos's uh his reportedly proposed to
Lauren Sanchez with a 2.5 million dollar
engagement ring and she's really excited
because she gets to keep it in the
divorce
just
taking a chance there for a role in his
newest movie actor Jude Law covered
himself in blood feces and sweat which
is unsurprising the film is being shot
on location in San Francisco
Two Cities
got two cities tonight
finally the NAACP has advised against
visiting Florida over policies it
considers hostile to Black Americans
like sending illegal immigrants to
Martha's Vineyard where Barack Obama
lives
now to some news even CNN hacks no no
one wants another cup of joe turns out
President Biden is not so popular with
the American people also the Sun is hot
laughs
CNN broke the news and it's horrible
news horrible for Joe Biden
horrible news horrible for Joe Biden our
new CNN two-thirds of all of the
American people surveyed 66 percent of
the public say that a Biden Victory
would either be a setback or a disaster
for the United States
setback or a disaster we've been in
disaster territory for a while now am I
right audience
I wish I had a Nerf football to throw
you people
but congrats to CNN for reporting
breaking news from 2019.
meanwhile the Surgeon General Supreme Dr
Jill fell flat while giving a speech in
Washington D.C yesterday saying she went
uh saying she went over like a lead
balloon would be an insult to my
favorite Led Zeppelin cover band lead
balloon
[Laughter]
I found that thing
that thicker than our divisions
and um I thought you might cop for that
you know you're on the road to Victory
when you're channeling this guy
you get back in the business of creating
a more peaceful world
please clap
[Applause]
given all the bad news I wonder what old
Joe's got to say
no no no no no my wife knows how to
motivate people she's a doctor and an
educator and a grandmother and a teacher
you know you want people to clap you ask
them to clap if you're happy and you
know a clap your hands clap clap did I
ever tell you the time I took our Corn
Pop with one hand behind her back I took
him behind the shed and I showed him a
thing or two and all right yeah you know
how that ends anyway
I like ice cream and sunglasses
Dagan Dagan what do you think do you
believe this poll and uh what do you
think it means oh yeah and I'd like to
explain to Jill what just happened in
country terms
uh
for three years now your turd talking
husband's been going around town calling
me a dirty old behind my back and
now you have the cans to stand up in
front of the Ladies Auxiliary in front
of me and talk about unity and coming
together not only am I not going to clap
for you I'm gonna boo you all the way
out into the parking lot
[Applause]
laying on the air horn All The Way
did you notice Dagan didn't have to say
could you please clamp after you said
Dr Drew uh you also have doctor in front
of your name do you does it bother you
when we tease Dr Jill with the doctor
thing that issue has bothered me since
the 80s when people adulterated The
Physician doctor yes musicologist and
everything else becomes a doctor the
term has no meaning anymore thank you
for holding back on your opinions
but these these polls are getting
actually confusing to me I had to write
some stuff down people need to be aware
though that 41 are calling him a
disaster right if it wins but 44 Trump
also saying the same thing and 26
percent say setback well here's where
Trump has the advantage only 12 saying
his presidency would be a setback really
also good news right it's good news also
uh something jumped out of being these
polls 40 he's got a 40 approval rating
the lowest since I wonder if anyone
alive knows this Dwight Eisenhower who
knew he was so unpopular I thought
everybody liked it I thought so too yeah
but these polls are teaching us things
and they're just confusing it's really
really again it's the Press deciding
what they want to report and where but
yeah I mean that I think polls are
different now because back in his day
people had to ride up on a horse and
yell into your window
right so I don't know if you can trust
the polls that are so far off cat uh do
you agree with CNN's reaction I mean you
got to hand it to Jake Tapper he was
giving him the bad news right
yeah it's giving him the bad news but
isn't like just watching Joe Biden the
bad news
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah
like have have they been watching their
guy and I think I'm done with people
saying that it's a age thing with Biden
because I think it's truly offensive to
everyone out there who's 80 years old or
older who can totally string a full
sentence together like
who or who totally you know only shakes
hands of people who are there or you
know who
who knows for sure who is alive and
who's dead and like who knows for sure
whether or not they were raised by
Puerto Ricans
Joe Biden loves to say the whole age is
just a number thing and honestly he has
taught me that that is true more than
anyone else but just not in the way that
he thinks
yeah because when he says age is just a
number your follow-up question is what
number are you talking about
and then he would say the number
well Tyrus I mean okay his numbers are
bad but were they ever good he ran from
the basement it didn't like it seemed
like people were very charged up about
him uh you know before I I think we need
to investigate what the hell was in the
basement
like was it Amityville Horror down there
where there's some some gases down there
was Corn Pop slanging drugs down there
like what was going on down there
because the in the all joking aside the
The Jig Is up everyone gets it now the
G7 speech was so bad that they realized
that he can't negotiate or present and
that's why for 97 days there's been an
appointment
to meet with the president with from the
GOP to discuss how we're going to fix
the debt ceiling and all this other
stuff and he won't meet with them and
they know why because they'd walk in and
MacArthur would come out and go with no
tie on going
we in trouble
yeah he's got what
six days left to get this done and all
they're asking is to meet with Joe and
the answer is no
yeah where if you work for the federal
government it's time for a side job
well Dr Drew you know you're citing some
interesting stats there but I also read
that Americans when asked they don't
really know why they're they want to
vote for somebody for president they can
tell you who they don't want to be
president right that's the most popular
answer well I know I don't want Joe
Biden or the thing on my left you've
created the two most unpopular
candidates and those are the two most
likely to be presidents yeah people
either don't want Trump or they don't
want Biden yeah and those are the top
Runners but is that I mean is that such
a bad way to go about it Degen I mean
yeah yeah I would agree but what
never happy with 100 happy with the
candidate I vote for it's the lesser of
two evils usually I vote for who I think
is going to do less damage to the
country and I can see four percent are
considering rfkg they were going to clap
from
buzz kill over there
uh I interruptedly so but Dagan I mean
you you're oftentimes I find You're
motivated by negative energy
I mean if that drives you excuse me
really well uh let's get somebody else
in the chair I
get one thing
and I remember when Trump was first
running everybody dismissed him
including me I called him the summertime
it was in 2015 the summertime boyfriend
it was like that everybody would forget
about who you hooked up with when you
were drunk on tequila for three months
and he wound up being president a little
more than a year later so whatever we
think we know now is absolutely dead
wrong but I blame Jill Jill needs to get
in charge of this if you have a friend
who constantly comes over every time she
comes to your house for a cocktail party
and her husband like barfs in your
bedroom or steals like steals your
volume out of the medicine cabinet you
don't blame him you blame her yeah I
like that why is she not in charge of
him
it's true okay up next hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not not get it anywhere else